الجزيرة. اتهمت الخارجية
الافغانية الولايات المتحدة
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلية
وفلسطينيين في القدس المحتلة مع
وعين الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيسا
له. فماذا يعني ذلك? امريكا تطلق
اطلقت صاروخا بالستيا قبالة
سواحلها الشرقية بدوره اكد حرس
تضع متارس حديدية بحرية لصد اي
هجوم برمائي مفاجئ للصين على
تهديداتها لروسيا لكن الضرر يلحق
بالدول الاوروبية وشريان الغاز
بانتهاك اجوائها بعد تحليق
طائراتها في الاجواء الافغانية.
الله. اصدر العاهل الملك سلمان
اوامر باعادة تشكيل مجلس الوزراء
سقوط العديد من الشهداء وجرح
تسعة اخرين. جيش الاحتلال
حظرها الدواء خلال جائحة كورونا
وممارستها ضغوطا كانت لقاحات
السواحل الياباني وقوع الحادث
وفق ما اوردته رويترز. تايوان
واع والحكومة تولي اهتماما
لمطالب الناس. كما لفت انه اذا
وزير الخارجية الايراني
عبدالهيان ان طهران ليست مكانا
كانت الولايات المتحدة قلقة على
الشعب فقد مات الاف الاطفال بسبب
مير استجابة لمطالب الفيدرالي
الامريكي وذلك بامر من الرئيس
النازي. العصا تنكسر. موهبة
الرقص على رؤوس الافاعي. نعم
والفوضى. لا يدري الشعب العراقي
من اين يمسك العصا? فلم تعد هناك
لاي شخص يريد فيها انقلابا او
ثورة مؤكدا ان الشعب الايراني
الرافدين من هذه الفوضى التي
يعيشها فسيادته منتهكة وسماؤه
حقيقية? الشعب يجيب ويخرج
احتجاجا على رفض البرلمان لها.
والسبب رفض مجلس النواب استقالة
الحلبوسي. فهل من مغيث يخرج بلاد
عصا ليمسكها اساسا. فالقصف الجوي
والمدفعي الايراني متواصل على
رئيسه محمد الحلبوسي فهل كانت
هذه الاستقالة شكلية وغير
البرلمان الالماني بتشبيه الرئيس
اردوغان بثأر المجاري يبدو ان
هناك تجددت الاشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين والامن العراقي
ومن الارادة التركية الى الادارة
الغربية حيث عمت حالة غضب عارمة
نشرت وسائل اعلام فلسطينية جانبا
من مواجهات واشتباكات دارت بين
الاوكرانيسكي. اردوغان الذي
يحاول الوساطة بين كييف وموسكو
مخترقة وارضه تتصحر وماءه يجف.
يا لها من مأساة. والتطورات. قال
قد يكون انهى فرص حصوله على تلك
الوساطة ام ان لبوتين رأيا اخر.
النازية. لكن الالمان يتساءلون
كيف تتناسى حكومتهم الام الماضي
ما يبدو ضربة اخرى للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بتنديده
خاصة في تركيا قررت ايقاف
التعامل مع نظام الدفع الروسي
ليخلق جوا من التوازن بين روسيا
وامريكا هنا العصا تنكسر ليجبره
الاسرائيلي يرفع حالة التأهب على
حدود لبنان استعدادا لمواجهة حزب
حفيد ارطغرل يلعبها باحترافية
بعد ان امسك العصا من المنتصف
برلين منذ نهاية الحرب العالمية
الثانية وحتى يومنا هذا. هذه
الدبابات كانت رمزا لانتصار
الاتحاد السوفيتي على المانيا
الوضع على اختيار طرف واحد. وبعد
ان ذكرت وكالة بلومبرج ان مصارف
لايران. من جديد قالت السلطات
الكورية الجنوبية ان بيونج يانج
في العاصمة برلين حول دبابات
سوفيتية متمركزة في العاصمة
برلين من الاراضي الاوكرانية
المحتلة التي اجرت فيها روسيا
الذي تناقش فيه المانيا ارسال
دباباتها الى اوكرانيا يدور جدل
الولايات المتحدة تقترب من حافة
خطرة مشددا على ان موسكو ستكون
الكمين. الثأر الروسي في برلين.
الحرب رائعة لاولئك الذين لم
يجربوها بعد. هنا المستشار
الالماني اولفشولز يقول موقف
دخان حزنها يتصاعد الى يومنا
هذا. وبمناسبة ذكرها وفي الوقت
تلو الاخر. العبارات السياسية هي
اقرب لبيت شعر غزلي. فالحرب
الروسية وهناك ايضا فارون من
جنسيات اخرى فمنهم من يفر من
بالاستفتاءات الروسية في المناطق
الاوكرانية بعد اتصاله بنظيره
السليماني شمالي العراق. في حين
يرفض البرلمان العراقي استقالة
استفتاءات لن يتغير. مؤكدا ان
الرئيس الروسي بوتين يرتكب الخطأ
الحرب ومنهم من يلبي نداء بلاده
بالعودة اليها. وهنا السفارة
وازمة دبلوماسية اروقة الحكومة
التركية بعدما قام نائب رئيس
حازمة وحازمة في الدفاع عن
اراضيها. فهل حانت ساعة الصفر
مغادرة روسيا على الفور. بينما
فقد رمضان قديروف ذراعه الايمن
نعم كشفت التقارير عن مقتل في
اوكرانيا بعد ان امطرته قوات
اوروبا في برد وخوف وظلام. قلبي
الصغير لا يتحمل. هروب جماعي.
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان. ياتي
الرئيس التركي مجددا ليوجه على
ليس هنالك نصيب للاتراك بالتماهي
مع سياسة اليس كذلك? العراق
امريكا والغرب وراءه. فهل يخاف
الروس مما يقوله الغرب? بوتين
لترد واشنطن وتحث الاوكرانيين
على استخدام الاسلحة المقدمة لهم
يرد. عازمون على انقاذ سكان
مناطق الاستفتاءات باوكرانيا.
من قبل الغرب في المناطق التي تم
الاستيلاء عليها. وهذا الاجراء
رئيسي. فهذه المناطق بعد
الاستفتاء ستكون روسية بحتة.
للتوعية بترشيد استهلاك الكهرباء
خلال الشتاء. شتاء كارثي ستعيش
وهنا ياتي سفير موسكو لدى واشنطن
اناتولي انتنوف ويحذر من ان
من شأنه ان يقرب الحرب. لان ذلك
يعتبر اعتداء على روسيا بشكل
تلك المناطق ها هي تنتظر اعلان
بوتين ضمها رسميا. تاركا تهديدات
كييف بوابل من القنابل والصواريخ
ولم يتم التأكيد متى حدث هذا
عندما يستأصل الجراح قطعا من
جسدك فانت تعاني. بينما اليوم ها
هنا هيئة الاذاعة والتلفزيون
الفرنسي تعرض نشرة مستقلة
هو الجراح الروسي بوتين من سيقوم
بالعملية وبعد نجاح الاستفتاء في
ومن انتظار قرار الضم الى انتظار
قرار العبور. فبعد قرار بوتين
التعبئة لارسال عسكريين للقتال
في اوكرانيا طوابير طويلة من
والحب يسقط في كليهما ضحايا.
فهنا اثار حرب عالمية ما زال
اليوم فها هو غاز روسيا يفوح في
الارجاء بعد تسرب الغاز من ها هي
سلمان يستلم مهمة جديدة. فما هي
هذه المهمة? امريكا تقطع شريان
سيارات الشباب الروسي الهارب
للدول المجاورة تملأ الحدود
الامريكية في موسكو تعلن حالة
الطوارئ وتدعو مواطنيها الى سرعة
واشنطن السبب يبدو ان الولايات
المتحدة تستعجل قطع الغاز الروسي
قبل ان تبدأ حرب اوكرانيا وعندما
سئل عن قال الرئيس الامريكي اذا
مصادفة. موسكو طلبت الرئيس
الامريكي بالكشف عما اذا كانت
بلاده تقف وراء تسرب الغاز وانتم
متابعينا. ما رأيكم هل تكون
قادرين على القيام بذلك. لكن كيف
ذلك لم يكن احد يدري حينها. اما
غزت روسيا مرة اخرى فلن يكون
هناك سننهي ذلك. اعدك اننا سنكون
روسيا. ليس كل ما ينطقه بايدن
زلة لسان برغم كثرة زلاته سابقا
تماما عن اوروبا. يا للكارثة
التي ستحدث. الكارثة حدثت حقا.
الفوضى دائما من الداخل فكيف
ستنتهي الازمة والامير محمد بن
للخيانة. اذا كنتم قلقين على
الشعب الايراني. فقد مات الالاف
بعده الحروب الموعودة وواشنطن
تحذر. بينما ذراع بوتين يتعرض
منه بسببكم. هكذا ردت طهران على
الولايات المتحدة. فما الذي يجري
اذا? اما كيم جونغ فيستمر
بهوايته المفضلة. وفي العراق
روسيا بخطوة وتطالب رعاياها
بالخروج الفوري من روسيا
كهذه? بينما روسيا تحضر لاجراء
جديد قد يتجاوز الزمن لتقترب
بايدن واليوم ها هو يفي بوعده.
فبماذا سترد موسكو لتسبق واشنطن
هكذا سنقطع شريان روسيا. فليورنا
بوتين ماذا سيصنع? هذا ما قاله
واردوغان يشمر عن ساعديه ويعلن
مواجهة موسكو. فهل نشهد مواجهة
لاوروبا ينقطع. فكيف سيكون حال
اوروبا بعد ذلك?